looks like there's no more him and I gez
and Halsey have reportedly called it
quits again she's really yeah she's
really brave she's an amazing person
she's so intelligent so insightful and
so you know just understanding that was
gez back in June gushing over his
ladylove
but now the couple has seemingly ended
their relationship for the second time
this year the crazy the split news comes
after a summer filled with ups and downs
for the couple who parted ways in July
after a year of dating only to get back
together in August and we have a similar
kind of perspective aesthetically on
creating music so we've loved each other
well according to reports the pair's
split happened over the weekend
[Music]
the 24 year old singer is currently in
Japan promoting her new music but her
seemingly former beau showed no signs of
a split when et spoke with him at the
radio comms 6th annual weekend survived
concert in Los Angeles on Sunday the 29
year old rapper had nothing but kind
words to say about Halsey she just put
out her single that's doing incredible
right now so I'm really happy for her
what was behind that cute birthday
Instagram that you wrote for her you
called her your queen just speaking from
the heart you know I think the world of
her she's a really special person a
really special human being that besides
you know how great of an artist she is
but you know as a human I love it and I
witness tells et gez was in good spirits
at the candy Halloween party in Los
Angeles just one day before noting he
had his own private table and there were
several girls there the eyewitness
claims gez appeared a very flirty with
the girls last time we saw the couple
together was on the red carpet at the
American Music Awards earlier this month
[Music]